how's it going res - spirit of hat oh
jeez oh jeez
welcome back today light um something at
the loading got stock side to restart
everything but we're practically back
okay I guess we're going in here this
place is a little filly I feel a little
more safe here Bryce I feel like we're
it's okay you know see they're smoking
cigars
Oh check oh damn I'm a genius
where's my genius at whoa what the hell
does that mean plus I did it I did it
Saturday new [ __ ] what what what why
what no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no this is a present
okay I'm not a present it's flares to
protect you I don't have any flash
do you give me the plate I could lay my
ass to place slaves land all right I'm a
dance that's what I'm not though I'm my
dance
if only Allen could see me now girl I
know you're there I don't know who the
[ __ ] you're talking to quite frankly I
think you need some help Sarah oh jesus
this creep isn't it [ __ ] aim be at
that ambience man okay from this point
on I'm now gonna swear well try not just
incur some [ __ ] mind I mean okay what
what oh god buckets Oh God not buckets
oh [ __ ] I hear them I hear them I hear
them
oh it's a dead end I don't have any
flags huh
did it go away he's go stick to find
clues but what if you don't have any
glow sticks what if you don't have any
glow sticks that
I never am named an eminent take [ __ ]
youring hello guys so we meet again
huh are you crying oh you're on fire
well boohoo tough [ __ ] man burning with
anger Oh Judas T yes I agree 110 percent
all right whatever but now you told me
and now I wasted it party okay they
wither in flames
hi temptation [ __ ] to back it all [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] any [ __ ] it a shiny little
please Jess I have on extra oh oh yeah
that's right you guys are tough now yeah
I'm the flame master designer from the
pasture I put some else on my passes
here stop it what had dark me and go
again oh no no don't you dare touch dose
it's trying to pull my cables and then
okay okay
and yeah stop your being okay we have
four out of six
oh no fun don't do that oh god oh god I
hate witches and I love [ __ ] I mean I
love [ __ ] I hate witches
I mean hey
okay let's just make sure we check every
corner I know you're there
well no [ __ ] [ __ ] genius way EDI you
duck mess I am handling so many shits at
detect and then phony I go to this place
is a lot bigger than that okay there it
is again I don't even know what to call
you
yeah yeah that's great
guess how many flares I have what do you
think what are you [ __ ] think with my
ducks in the tits in the space and the
universe and lettuce will keep them at
bay huh but what if I don't have any
goddamn flames okay I don't have [ __ ]
time for you right now I'm busy dying
like a little schoolgirl
I hear foot I'm stuck goddamn Chaz
you're working against me Jesus thought
we were Bros well if I had Flint's I
would use them I would use my flowers I
am desperate from someplace I want to
flat it up in my butt
don't quote me on that sir I don't know
where the [ __ ] I am
oh I don't know quite [ __ ] I am just
wanna find me some place girl just wanna
find me some fresh flowers get it
flowers please anything with the friends
if I don't look my I don't look
I got all the remnants
I got Nate don't make out with me in
public falling lightly at it why oh it's
not scary well have you played it
huh no you haven't there so I flare
there's a gold stick that [ __ ] keep no
now I find all the players that's great
oh are you cereal I don't even want to
milk it right now man I'd get water eat
what in the heavens are you doing don't
smack my face in public we talked about
this not in public you little [ __ ] for
flares for ha ha ha ha
I looked into all the cabinets in space
man there was no there was neither maybe
I should start using the goddamn map it
is a little I knew this would be him
don't [ __ ] get sing a new song
ok I'm letting a flare on this wait how
do I lit flares oh hello I need you
officer kicks ok cool we found this
place I get the feeling he's gonna
attack me soon they're gonna attack
they're gonna attack with some gun nice
going chair very nice chip chap cheerio
who has time to read in moments like
this you had to be ultimate badass of
2011 Oh God don't [ __ ] out on me now
Sarah oh god I I thought I saw a face
English mother mattress s not you too
okay we got this we got this book in the
bag I don't think that's how you say it
but it could be how you say it I don't
want - okay - [ __ ] hell I should have
scared me more than it did but it didn't
some bad aunts cuz I'm bad at aints cuz
I'm badass is anyone buying this nope
well good I'm not gonna continue uh okay
when you just want more they could be in
like chocolate factors hey don't fight
me Dora please no please not now no no
no I'm living a fairy
oh she liked it man keep finding flares
but I don't need
right now actually I do where's the last
one take them out it's too I'm too
scared to [ __ ] zoom in on it
where oh geez
this is my last flare
after this I'm all alone
anybody there yeah oh oh god oh god oh
god oh god please see if there it's not
a fly it's not a flyer okay okay okay
all right
we're gonna [ __ ] do it if that I
think I'd have a [ __ ] dough and see
that we're gonna go this we gotta go
down this all the way that's right I
gotta go honey told me nice and easy
nice and slow she is chasing me but I
doesn't make me want to go down to funky
town girl I want to go down a foggy day
I wanna go dancer described on the
really cake don't you then don't you
worry don't you hurry time I don't huh
such brutality okay wait wait wait okay
forward right and special-interest
forward okay I can't see because you're
backing that can't figured that can't be
good not looking back don't look back Oh
God Oh chief dicks
come on cow man
come on come on come on come on trouble
my [ __ ] G huh oh my but a
little look it's easy
well that's too [ __ ] bad girl at
system [ __ ] bad let's just wait until
it saves hopefully it will I probably
won't cuz that's my luck god it's
reflecting our fears there Oh hallelujah
alright gonna end this episode we're
bros live like you [ __ ] have to get
this guy to come over today I see Bruce
love your boots